[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute möchte ich euch ein
grundrezept für eine leckere creme
zeigen und zwar benutze ich die creme
später als topping für cupcakes das ist
eine leckere fische frisch käsecreme ihr
könnt aber auch zb stattdessen einfach
etwas mascarpone nehmen ich brauche an
zutaten 200 gramm schlagsahne 250 g
frischkäse oder mascarpone etwas
sonderbar zwei bis drei esslöffel butter
zucker und etwas vanille extrakt und
wenn ihr das jetzt umwandeln wollte zum
beispiel in der zitronencreme können
dennoch abgeriebene zitronenschale mit
dazu geben oder einfach am truman zuerst
gebe ich jetzt die sahne in troisdorf es
dann schlag ich sie ganz kurz an und
gebt dann zwei teelöffel sein apartment
reines hilft einfach dass die sahne
steif wird und später dann auch auf den
capex standfest bleibt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
an warmen tagen mache ich es übrigens so
dass ich mir immer so ein akku kühlpads
darunter läge beim sahne schlagen dann
gewinnt die sahne nämlich nicht so
schnell oder eben gar nicht als nächstes
nehme ich mir eine größere rolle
schüssel und gibt den frischkäse rein
das sind jetzt auch alle zutaten schön
kalt dann der puderzucker mit dazu
einfach nach belieben nach bedarf ich
gehe jetzt noch vanille extrakt mit dazu
dass vanille frosting und auch hier gebe
ich noch zwei teelöffel sommerbad mit
rein und die zutaten wenn jetzt kurz bei
niedriger stufe verrührt
[Musik]
und jetzt nur noch die sahne unterheben
und man könnte jetzt hier an der stelle
auch noch etwas geschmack mit
reinbringen in form von zb oreo keksen
die kann man vorher im mixer ganz aktie
kleinen da hat man nämlich so ein oreo
kekse shopping oder man nimmt zwei
esslöffel pürierte früchte oder eben
einfach was anderes
also das war nicht so meine ideen was
habt ihr da auch eigene ideen
[Musik]
das ist jetzt die fertige kriegen ich
gebe es jetzt noch ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank sowie etwa 15 minuten dann
wird sie nämlich noch mal ein bisschen
fester und dann können diese entweder
mit einem löffel auf muffins auftragen
oder einfach mit einem spritzbeutel und
ich hoffe dass ich dieses rezept
gefallen hat dieses grundrezept ihr habt
ganz viele variationsmöglichkeiten und
die genauen mengenangaben stehen alle
noch mal auf sase - blog.de
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]